I was so excited when Apple finally gave
us Wi-Fi 6E in the new 2023 MacBook Pros
but then I found out it was kind of
garbage for two reasons but with that
for some people it actually might be
amazing and I also found out that these
new machines are actually incredible for
Wi-Fi speeds even without Wi-Fi 6E so
this is going to be probably the most
detailed comparison because not only did
I upgrade my internet but I also bought
a new Wi-Fi router to maximize the
speeds and I tested a bunch of different
locations in multiple modes to give you
guys the best information on if these
new machines are really going to help
you and who should actually upgrade your
router and which one you should get now
before I jump in I have to let you guys
know about our giveaway of an Mt Pro 14
inch MacBook Pro and a Mac Mini and all
I have to do is be subscribed enable
notifications and comment down below low
you can even go back to our older video
since the announcement of these machines
up to February 1st which is tomorrow and
that's when we're going to announce the
winners so watch old videos comments and
good luck now I've had gigabit internet
at my house for a while now but I didn't
upgrade my router or modem because the
2021 16 inch and 14-inch MacBooks
couldn't even max out the signal that I
had and my router cost me 350 dollars
it's very well rated people are still
buying that one today but with these new
systems and Wi-Fi 6E I had to finally
make the jump now this new ASUS router
it is very expensive but I wanted to
maximize the capabilities of these
MacBooks so I finally made the jump but
now I think it wasn't worth buying Wi-Fi
6E now I tested seven different
locations throughout my house in my yard
and the first one was in my living room
above my actual route outer now with the
old MacBook that could only do Wi-Fi six
the fastest I used to get was 705
megabit per second but upgrading to the
new router I actually jumped up to
841. that was nice but still not gigabit
speeds Now using Wi-Fi 5 with the new
16-inch MacBook Pro I got 1099 megabit
per second which blew my mind because it
was even faster than what I'm paying for
and that's without Wi-Fi 6E switching
over to the six gigahertz band I got a
thousand and Ninety Six slightly slower
but still my full rated speed and this
is where I noticed the first issue even
though we hit that peak of 1096 the
speed didn't stay there it ramped up to
that and then it slowed down finishing
at about 800 megabit per second where
with Wi-Fi 5 it was consistently fast I
switched the laptop to high power mode
because I thought maybe this is a
battery saving issue because why else
would it speed up and then slow down but
unfortunately I didn't notice any
differences it still would ramp up and
then slow down so I updated to the
latest firmware on the router and the
issue was still there now the reviews
for this router are amazing I couldn't
find anybody else having this issue so I
thought it must be something with the
new MacBooks either the way Apple
designed them or maybe it's a firmware
issue or something like that but this is
something that is consistently happening
at least half the time if not more so if
you guys know why this is happening
please let me know in the comments now
the next location I tested was in my
living room sitting on my couch here I
used to get 663 megabits per second it
got a little faster with the new router
but with the new Macbook I got a
thousand a hundred and fifty 59 just
with Wi-Fi 6 and then a thousand 162
with Wi-Fi 6E now how is this possible
that the new MacBooks are so much faster
using the same exact router everything's
the same other than the MacBook using
Wi-Fi six well I noticed that when it is
connecting in the details of my Wi-Fi
instead of connecting a 1200 megabit per
second it is connecting a 2 400 megabit
per second so the chip inside the laptop
is much better even if you only have
Wi-Fi six so if you're buying one of
these new laptops you will get faster
speeds if you don't change anything with
your internet setup and not only do the
speeds matter but what matters more so
is if you are in a further area of your
house or you are in your backyard and
you have a weak signal it will get much
better which I will show you the next
spot I tested was in my home theater
downstairs and I went from 620 megabits
per second all the way up to 904 with
Wi-Fi 6 and 855 with Wi-Fi 6E so the
difference was pretty awesome now you
also notice that the new router with the
old laptop actually got slower I don't
know if that's a fluke or what happened
but with that Wi-Fi 6E was actually
slightly slower with the new laptop than
Wi-Fi 6. but the next location I tested
was the couch in the far side of my
basement here I used to get 569 megabit
per second got a little faster the new
router but with a new laptop I got
802 which is 40 faster and faster than
even the best speeds I ever got close to
the Wi-Fi router with the old laptop
which is great because I'm paying for
this internet now you also might notice
that with Wi-Fi 6E and that spot it was
actually slower
657 slower than the old laptop with
Wi-Fi 6. now why is that happening well
that is because the way Wi-Fi 6 is
designed is it is supposed to be super
fast but it actually doesn't penetrate
through walls and Floors as good as
Wi-Fi five so the further you are and
the more things in the way the slower it
gets and in some cases you just won't
want to even use it now I have to pause
and give you guys a major benefit of
Wi-Fi 6E and the six gigahertz band if
you're in a location that has a bunch of
other Wi-Fi signals and routers for
example apartments condos and very
densely populated areas your Wi-Fi can
Clash with other people's Wi-Fi and
having the six gigahertz band will
literally ignore those other signals and
give you full performance where you
might have major slowdowns previously
now in my case I have a big property so
that's not an issue but that's something
to consider now the next location was
the furthest basement bedroom now here
the fastest I ever got was 439 and if
you look at the rest of the results with
the new router and the new Macbook it
actually did not get any faster which
was a disappointment so if you have a
tough spot in your house in this case
it's behind concrete you just might need
stronger antennas or a mesh system now
one area where I really have issues is
in my backyard and my front yard a lot
of times if I'm mowing the lawn I just
don't have a signal on my phone it's
connected to Wi-Fi but stuff stops
playing and that's a disconnect and it
sucks now the first area I tested was
the playhouse that I'm building that I'm
still working on now previously the
fastest I got was 97 megabit per second
upgrading to a new router with slightly
faster 102 but that doesn't tell the
whole story now you may have noticed
that I haven't been talking about upload
load speeds and that's because my
internet doesn't have fast uploads the
fastest rated for is 15 megabit per
second so pretty much everywhere I get
that until I go outside now in this
Playhouse the fastest I would get is 5
megabit per second upload which is very
slow and that went up to 14 megabit per
second so that's almost three times
faster it was a really nice boost
especially if you have security cameras
up or anything else now with the new
Macbook I went up to 127 as far as
download for Wi-Fi 6 and the upload was
15 which is great but with Wi-Fi 6E I
couldn't even get a signal out there now
sometimes it would connect to Wi-Fi 60
but the internet wouldn't work and then
it would stall out and wait and
disconnect it sucked and the last spot I
tested was my front yard where I have a
security camera hung up but it has Wi-Fi
issues now previously the fastest speed
I would get is 17 megabit per second
that jumped up to 24 just with the new
router but as far as the upload it went
from four all the way up to 15 which is
great because the camera needs to upload
the video footage so that I can watch it
so that was awesome now with the new
laptops I got 36 megabit per second as
far as download and once again 15 for
the upload which is awesome but with
Wi-Fi 6E once again I had no signal at
all because it's going through multiple
walls to go outside now that just kind
of killed the whole idea of Wi-Fi 60 for
me just because the Wi-Fi 6 was so fast
with the new laptops that even with
gigabit I didn't even need Wi-Fi 6E and
the Wi-Fi 60 routers are twice as
expensive as Wi-Fi six so what I learned
from all of this is one apple didn't
tell us that the Wi-Fi 6 itself got
twice as fast as far as the maximum
connection speed and that with that
update itself you don't really need
Wi-Fi 6E unless you have some crazy two
gigabit 10 gigabit which almost nobody
has and with that the Wi-Fi 6E it just
doesn't go very far and sometimes it can
also cause issues so my recommendation
for all of you guys is one if you're
struggling with internet speed and
you're considering upgrade to a new
Macbook Pro if you get one of these new
14 or 16 inches that's going to help you
a lot and two if you do want to upgrade
your router and you have multiple walls
and you're dealing with signal issues
well you don't even need to buy a Wi-Fi
6E router like I did for a lot of money
so I'm impressed with the new connection
speed but not really with Wi-Fi 6E so
you guys let me know your thoughts down
in the comment section below if you want
to buy one of these new MacBooks use a
YouTube shopping feature right there
click that Circle above to subscribe to
see more videos on these new MacBooks
check out one of those videos and I'll
see you in the next one
[Music]